[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hey guys welcome to a very special
episode of game spot live but joining me
today is Chad hello happy we're gonna
play some foreign ideas have a little
fun you know yes we're gonna be playing
some fortnight on this awesome awesome
be sponsored by MSI so Chad I know your
bit of a battle royale connoisseur hello
season in the Br yeah if you guys
dunderhead chad is he's a twitch
streamer who plays a lot of battle
royale games plays out a fortnight a lot
of pub G yeah pub G my go-to and later
on in the stream I'm going to show you
guys more about the MSI gt70 v Titan but
for right now we're gonna cut to some
gameplay so Chad yeah it was good
how do you feel about for a night or
night um I've enjoyed fortnight I've
been I've enjoyed seeing another sort of
VR game kind of enter the space and you
know blow up as big as it did and for
tonight you know it really took the
world by storm in terms of just you know
mainstream audience and I think it
really helped you know get to where it
is so you guys who are watching us now
I'm gonna be taking your questions in
chat on YouTube on GameSpot and on
Chad's streaming as well we're hosting
Chad so hi Chad fans what's up boys
what you guys doing welcome to games v
I'll get it
come up you used to like climb out of my
element you know it's gonna breathe yeah
you're out of it you're out of your room
yeah the lights camera the action
so I know you play a lot of pubsey and
this this is always and we start we're
getting some fan noise here you have to
get down all the way on that guy
yeah well are you gonna oh it's off now
sorry for you guys watching could hear
the fans on the GT 75 Titan there is a
manual fan so you can keep the
temperature cool in the laptop keep
these cold do you know yes so it doesn't
overheat but what I was saying before is
there's sort of this uninhabitable
conversation that happens when talking
about battle royale games and that is
the pub g2 format comparison and then
you play a lot of both yeah I like I
hate the whole argument it's kinda like
sports teams right like a lot of people
can't really just be a fan of one
they're like no I do I'm a die-hard pub
you player I'm a die-hard four denied
play you know like screw the other game
but like if there's a spate there's a
space for both of them right and each
will have the respective player bases
but I hate seeing that sort of friction
it caused just you know because I mean
there's gonna be a ton more new BR games
they're gonna continue to come out and
you know everyone's gonna have their own
take on it it's just like a popular
thing right now so I mean you know I
wish people were more con just open to
playing whatever and just you know being
fans of their game but kind of make like
it you know a fight out of it
necessarily like stacking one against
the other all the time and accepting
that they're both fun they're different
games they're popular for different but
similar reasons right right battle
royale is sort of like the thing right
now so yeah there's there's a bunch of
newbies coming out still even people are
just everyone's trying to pull them out
right now it's all the rage you know
your your chat is very excited to see
you
oh yeah yeah I miss my boys they said
you're looking very fine today let's go
they're extending you some good vibes
that's what's up baby
so we have a question from Bob Jones in
our chat what about the radical Heights
people yeah that's right radical Heights
ISM it's seen some love I think it's not
the response they expected when they
like launched another BR game you know
mm-hmm oh nice but I think it definitely
has its own little space amongst the VR
games right it's it's more quirky than
for a night it has like some of the same
elements in terms of just how like light
and sort of casual it is I guess mm-hmm
but I got played a little bit on stream
actually and I really enjoyed my time on
it yeah it needs work right but uh it
was like it is a fun like little
refreshing experience like a nice new
take on the FDR in general and they're
working on it a lot so what happens that
um I was gonna ask you what is your
favorite loadout and I just think coming
through your loop here making your
choices um I usually like to run double
shotty fortnight you know they had like
the whole double pump thing for a while
where the pump shotgun pump shotguns
like nuts right does it ton of damage
and you could like just run two of them
on the same like in two different slots
and just like basically semi-auto just
keep switching them right yeah pump pump
so that got nerve this is just like
super OFI yeah I remember when I first
started playing that's what people were
doing it and it was pretty intense so
since then I've been a fan of just
trying like the other combos because
people like still double pump but it's
not necessarily just like with a pump
right they'll uh they'll run like a tack
shotgun a pump like I'm doing now you
know mm-hmm
or with the addition of the heavy
shotgun to that thing's pretty nuts
actually so I usually run like a pump in
them
find a finding on
Chad you are underrated pretty cool
watching play hey do you think you're
underrated Chad I think I'm probably
like rated pretty fairly fairly readin
oh you can't really rate yourself you
know oh that's true that's true I kill
for will asked what does Chad look for
in a battle royale game um what do I
look for in a battle royale game
well combat mechanics are obviously
super important I think something that's
really overlooked not Justin like VR
games but uh but uh not just like in VR
games but in lost shooters in general
nowadays movement movement I feel like
it's something that's super overlooked
when it comes to any shooter FPS or like
third-person it's like one of the most
essential parts of the game in the
combat so just like something with like
a really solid movement um kind of
layout and then you know just like good
combat mechanics nice I know you're
saying you started a little bit in the
ARMA 3 days yeah yeah I played like a
lot of army that's why I kind of just
transitioned into pup you so easily
because I play a lot dayz and armor and
stuff like that and I have played some
of the ARMA 3 BR not as much as other
people but I dabbled a little bit so I
kind of when pubs you came out that was
why I got into it so easily right I can
I already knew all the mechanics they're
very similar to games like dayz and ARMA
mm-hmm
so just like easy to pick it up and it
felt really good the the shooting Styles
really satisfying and did you start
playing pub G in the very beginning when
yeah it's late uh there was like an
alpha before I ended up playing that
went down and then I played and they did
like a closed beta period yes that's
when I
I feel like getting into it for the
first time and none of the the bugginess
an attorney away who stuck me though I
like actually wasn't even that into it
when I was playing in beta I was like oh
that's pretty cool like we'll see what
happens there when it launched I just
like couldn't put it down
and that's what you start streaming it
all the time yeah that's when I started
like streaming like super hardcore again
nice and then for me yeah
porn I came out or nights fun though
enjoy it even though I love puppies like
puppies like that's just my game you
know me but uh like fortnight's a nice
like change of pace switch it up a
little bit it's a lot more casual too
you know not everyone because in pub do
you everyone gets real sweaty but for
tonight like there's some people that
aren't very good and you'll see them in
a lot of your games you know yeah yeah I
still feel like that about pub G
sometimes though yeah yeah yeah you do
see like you do still refer to them as
bots you know yeah the bots if you guys
are just joining us right now
chad is playing on the GT 75 Titan
brought to you by MSI we're gonna be
showing up some of the specs of this a
little bit later but that's what that's
what he's operating on
Oh God super mega came says that boy
Chad answering questions and whatnot
isn't any worse question and I know what
we have a question in our chat here
plate awesome if you played each one
good fillets room yeah interestingly
enough we mean like some of the how many
of you guys know like some of those guys
we we played h1 when it first came out
and it was there was a survival game
that's what kind of like keep their
interest in it it was because we were
like pretty big into dayz at the time
and the survival game like aspects of it
was a really interesting myth so we're
like oh hype another like zombie kind of
survival thing you know maybe we'll be
sick and so we started playing when it
was just like the survival mode and when
the beer came out it is pretty fun I
think there are a lot of issues though
just in general with the game and we
just kind of all like fell out I guess
in terms of playing it a lot we just
kind of just moved on other stuff yeah I
think that's what a lot of players yeah
yeah ended up feeling and now that
others some other VR games you know a
little competition I know and they just
keep getting better - what did you think
of the that little stunt they pulled
with Auto Rio
I thought the auto real thing was pretty
cool it uh oh nice okay you can have any
given point you can just like zone back
into the game I don't want to distract
it too much I'm here with you what's it
look like
I hold a conversation sometimes I'm
shall focus I find that in chat I find
that when I'm streaming I have a hard
time keeping the conversation going a
chat because I get locked in yeah
well if I gets life turn out boy yeah
well I guess I wanted to get a victory
where I'm going you got to get at least
one win here where is this thing going
[Applause]
isn't one
yeah you're probably just gonna have to
hit me with that question again no it's
okay no no it is okay I want to know
hello hi what's going on I know you're
just like talking about the autorai oh
oh yeah stream yeah yeah we did some I
did some sponsor streams actually um
it's fun it's fun just like hop on with
your homies and just just drive around
have a good time I am you know the
self-proclaimed the best h1z1 all to
rail driver on the planet nice is that
is that serious or no like I'm actually
pretty good to drive it okay you can
probably know this about me I used to uh
I competed in rocket League before I
started like screaming of the our games
so you are nice at driving yeah
so I kind of just like I don't know I
don't know if it actually had anything
to do with like the rock league
experience but I kind of probably picked
up the driving again pretty quickly
that's fair
did you ever find that some people who
were like not as efficient at building
in for tonight often just build a box
around themselves yeah I like this guy
yeah that's me
I'm like I can't really build anything I
could also not with
Oh
nice nice almost kills you forgot a game
Olin for tonight yeah I'm trying to
think because I'm really played for
tonight too much I think I had somewhere
close to twenty one time now you know
it's not bad I think if I grinded out a
little bit I can do some pretty like
high kill games yeah
what's happening in today's stream I
mentioned it earlier today guys but we
are we have Chad here in the GameSpot
office so if you're on Chad's channel
and you're really confused right now
I that's why he's that's why he's not
home yeah he's hanging out with us today
in San Francisco where did some playing
some fortnight
I mean he's killing it on this MSI gt70
v Titan it's a gaming laptop it's fully
specked out I'm gonna be reading those
off for you guys later
try my best to bring home a duppy doing
the best
Chad come home I'm sorry mr. chippy
comes in came into our chat hi mr. Jaffe
welcome to spot said my boy Chad my boy
my boy Chad what's your thoughts this is
from sin scene go chat with your
thoughts on these waters days my fault
on wood horse days brick I'm so sorry
that you just lost that like that's good
worst days w arz days Oh War Z is Z
where Z days were sick that's like kind
of when I first gotten into which like
just as a whole
watching someone G he was a he was kind
of like a CS streamer he played like War
Z a lot he was like one of the like the
bigger streamers on the platform at the
time right because it's which wasn't
anywhere near the size it is now yeah
when was that
Oh 2011-2012 yeah something like that
yeah sorry guys that I said worse yeah
flamie now just just do it now get it
over with
yeah there's some word there's Boyz II
vets I'd be pretty pissed about yeah I
know they're mad it's okay it's okay
come on though I didn't really play it
too much yeah since never really played
too much but I watched a decent bit on
switch that's why it's sort of just
gotten to the whole platform goop chata
youtuber a chad is a twitch streamer but
he does have a youtube channel as well
where he does all the highlights and
stats though I shouldn't uploading again
nice I know I noticed because I was
stalking her
ya know some of your montages are pretty
funny I saw you had a to be one yeah
yeah and like my friend Justin we're we
just got like duh baby
aw end just like destroyed the whole
server yes yeah it's fun having games
like that yeah that was pretty fun to
watch so your roommate bring you nachos
another yeah yeah Josh so I've lived you
know Josh Oh G we lived together and
yeah he brought me a fat played nachos
the other day yeah that's my guess
so that was like a very very nice thing
for yeah that was he making up for each
other
make sure that's nice they were just
some very friendly nachos
they weren't guilty nachos oh I see
I wouldn't have seen that guy I would
have died there this little Dyke
probably through my brightness up a
little bit
hopefully looks good enough on stream
for you guys
I mean your chat is wild they seem like
a fun group though yeah their don't fit
though they're probably a little riled
up today's the special event yes and now
we got a girl on screen so yeah oh they
are they seem to be excited that you are
doing things yeah yeah they've been a
pretty pumped I'm starting like make
some news 2018 you know and they've just
been excited for me it's awesome
he's going back through the chat guys if
you're on YouTube as well I am reading
the comments so they just say the game
is a bit dark I don't know if there's
something we can do about that at this
current moment but maybe after then
after this one
resistant
water
do you this is a good one from Julio
Romero on YouTube is the Battle Royale
trend has it peaked or is there still
room for growth I think no one's really
hit the nail on the head yet when it
comes to like a VR game I think there's
a lot of them coming out but they're not
necessarily approaching it the right way
I think you know like any random dev
team could easily develop a VR game but
has like their own unique twist that
kind of just like those all the right
things that will overtake even like for
tonight I mean for tonight was kind of
that game that did it right like they
just they just blew up so big yeah and
just made the whole VR John era that
much bigger but I still think someone's
gonna come along and like really do it
right hey Matt wizard oh god she's
reading the comments runs in hives
that's YouTube in a nutshell yeah I I
think that for new games the space is a
little bit crowded right now yeah so I
don't think well my personal feelings is
that something like radical Heights
whenever right right some of these kind
of games are just gonna slip through the
cracks well someone does it like really
right and I think even for a game like
h1z1 like I don't think there's gonna be
a comeback for that game yeah I mean I'm
hoping to see you come back because I
always enjoyed my time playing h1 and
they're doing their whole like Pro
League kickoff and everything now but I
do hope too that they kind of just get
together and you know cuz I have a lot
of friends that were the biggest thing
for me too and it comes a shoshanna's I
had a lot of friends that were involved
with like the pro scene or you know the
scene in general and kind of seeing that
game fall off a little bit like suck
Drake because those guys were kind of
like lost they weren't sure what they
should do they're all trying to
transition other games so especially
like the VR teams
yeah and I know a lot of them have
struggled and a lot of them have even
just kind of disappeared so I'm hoping
that a see little surge and maybe
they'll come back and you know get some
opportunities definitely
vending machines how do you feel about
them pretty cool there boy and with the
No am I gonna take that I had to
incoming come say hi even even carriers
lives
oh nice oh that was good sound on that
always whenever I see somebody both
towards me like that for an annual it's
over for me
it is all about the high ground it
really is if they start coming at you
you sky start run at them ramp all the
way up try again top of them
yeah in the build war the build wars
have you ever played the PvE on this
game before I have yeah
did you play before the real thing this
thing yeah yeah it's like back in the
day uh like it was like maybe a year ago
at this point maybe not that long
exactly how long the VR for this has
been out but uh I played a little bit of
it like save the world game-mode with my
friend Josh mm-hmm and it was like chill
it definitely didn't have the appeal
that the game does now with like the VR
and all the cosmetics and everything
definitely well like at the base of it
like it's a pretty solid game at random
a smoothly like you know you shoot the
zombies and you know you're not like
lagging anywhere do you thinking or
anything like that
so like at the base that games like
pretty solid that's why they've been
able to like transition gonna be are so
long you know yeah definitely it was
already a good game before got around so
it was like I mean like the foundation
was there right right game was super
functional all the elements of the game
worked right yeah so they just so like
turn it all into a new game mode it was
like you know
if before tonight's been around pretty
smooth a lot longer than people realize
I think yeah been development for like I
don't even know how long right yeah no
early like this time last year or around
this time last year I remember we were
doing features on fortnight this is
before that way off so yeah it was
definitely it's it's been around let's
just sort of David you know it's it's
big new life yeah I heard someone shoot
over here I was going to say do you feel
like playing the PvE it all helped you
with the building at all or was it
really just getting in there and like
being forced so yeah not really I kind
of just like once the BR came out and I
wasn't like super on the hype when it
first came out so I'd like watch other
streamers that were playing it and
that's how I got just picked up on the
building like in the PvE like I hate to
say it but like when we were playing the
PvE we didn't even like build at all
like it was just cuz we're just like
Amer's right like we both came from my
counter-strike background you know we're
a pretty good FPS game so we just kind
of like shot all the zombies when they
died fast enough you know you know we
just wiped them before they could even
get close enough oh no oh nice no yes
it's a ball damage I forgot the whole my
bridge I'm gonna put that I thought you
were gonna like to a clutch save there
yeah I try yeah I thought that was the
end of me whole
have you ever accent I just like falling
off of the super-high for yeah yeah I'll
just be running I'll be like placing
ramps and then I like ramp won't place
or like I just won't place it and I'll
just fall off and you know goodbye how
boys it's always fun embarrassing
yourself you know yeah a vanishing when
you stream cuz you're gonna run into
those moments yeah
Aaron Jones ass pigging spa can you
please ask Chad if he's heard up or
we'll play ringing silence oh we got at
it oh no oh no wait give a moment
[Applause]
oh my god
this boy go he's in one of these boxes
did you build a box around him it's
possible
we've various yeah oh yeah yep
you just creep and I got no HP little
genius
this is pretty impressive my eyes going
up
what oh my god
no run Matt's dead no that was awesome
wow that was crazy
gotta go Sam ah materials love oh no no
and no meds no campfires come on man you
had nothing for me he had nothing for
you he had nothing for you that was
awesome app now yeah but that was crazy
so he asked yeah what was that question
yeah
hold on finding it again ring of asylum
have you heard of it I haven't so I
can't I can't elaborate we just have
somebody who wants to know if you're
gonna be playing ring of asylum at all
um perhaps Gilligan to see you a ring of
Elysium Elysium um I think I have heard
of it I don't really think too much on
it though so I don't know we'll see I'll
probably like I'm probably gonna try
everybody our game that coming though my
brain won't like dyslexia oh yeah yeah
I'll probably just try like everybody
our game that comes up you know since my
falling tamina from puppy especially
yeah and you enjoyed our games a little
more than just like other stuff they
want to see how it stacks up yeah right
especially anything new like that yeah
[Applause]
we have a question in the game spot chat
what kind of games - Chad play growing
up Oh what kind I played growing up hmm
a little bit of everything
I guess my gaming career like initially
took off when I was really young
we had like a I think we had like
Windows 98 or something on a PC and we
mean my brother who played like games
like Knights and merchants like work the
old Warcraft games old counter-strike
and stuff like that and then unlike the
other side I also played I got played a
lot of Xbox around up like I had a bunch
of consoles n64 so you can intend to all
that stuff you know and then uh I ended
up getting like an original Xbox and was
a big like xboxone fanboy I guess and
this one Sony but let's call them X
ponies
and it's getting light he's
I feel bad I feel like Xbox crowd gets a
lot of a lot of [ __ ] thrown out them
from all the sudden you can boys out
there yeah yeah they're always like oh
my constant superior that's like though
oh it has been the thing for a long time
except I guess not with Xbox when I
suppose it's pretty powerful console
yeah this man is a Ghostbuster duties
going through walls yeah I saw that
so was that like a just a server thing
can explain it on this can we blame that
like it's everything I think so
for tonight they changed the mechanics
so like how the game works so like a
wall or a staircase or anything you
builds like one actually solidify if
there is a player like within it right
so like if you if you if you have a wall
that's like half in the ground and
you're standing you try to put a ceiling
on that and you're like standing in it
it won't actually be solid I'm time
everyone's clear out of it and then it
builds and then it like been neck so
because he was like he was like kind of
already jumping so he was kind of
already in the staircase when I put it
down so he just like went right through
they like changed how it worked I used
to be like a little different and I was
actually sure but they changed how it
worked so it's just like the thing that
causes many issues but now people
they're going through walls and I think
it's like better if they is kind of like
place like it forced the players out of
the wall it's like either side like
right away
mm-hmm that way you don't you know that
doesn't happen like based on like how
far they're through to like one side you
know based on percentage or something
like that
gotcha gotcha because I was definitely
curious one time I got shot through a
door and uh well no it wasn't her door
was like actually through a wall in um
gee this was in the beginning though so
I'll just obviously in the game um it
just never seems fair yeah but there's
just been so many issues with like just
server and vsync issues and whatever it
is people cheating I just like using
Enoch
yeah yeah I feel like I feel like a lot
more people have had worse experience
when it comes to cheaters like we will
run into Cheetos especially like the
stream sniper ones that just like Paulo
send every game like cheat yeah but I
feel like I don't really run the
cheaters too often maybe it's like look
like first person rather than third
person I know a lot of cheetahs are in
third person but that was never like
really something an issue that I ran
into in public so much more so just like
so very shoes and weird like laggy stuff
but yeah earlier on we so we asked the
question about what you believe me were
growing up and you were going into the
Xbox thing I end up getting into
original Xbox and then I got a 360 and
like played you know I'll call duty like
all that stuff just grown up and then I
kind of that's you know that's where I
start in terms of like gaming and I made
my transition to go like PC I played
like we had a family thing sea-ice plan
but I finally ended up building my own
computer in like 2012 yes I was
that's around the time I built mine as
well yeah before that I was all console
ok
PlayStation though yeah it was like it
was like I'm coming cuz I would play
like a bunch of PC games ah yeah you
didn't even turn around you open the
door he was not even there
I would play a lot of PC games on like
the family computer right so it's gonna
be like in the
malaria and gaming all day on the family
computer head like me my fans
yeah just playing I was making like
Counter Strike I played like a lot of
Garry's Mod ahead life games you know
nice nice
but me my brother like had to take turns
because we both like want to play God I
had to like rotate like every hour or
whatever was there like consoles and
stuff those nice like finally build now
you'll see and just be able to must have
been the day Jill yeah it was great it
was a great day
I'll go
all diversity you like burst all versus
worth that
[Applause]
I'd like to plan a laptop free cold oh
that's Capilano dude okay
what's conscious how does a good plan a
laptop um it's different it's definitely
not something I'm used to but uh like
pretty pretty smooth like transition I
guess yeah you know not being like used
to I'm just so used to my own gear right
because I play on that like ten hours a
day so just like the transition using a
different setups always a little weird
but in terms of like playing on this
it's a I mean like it's really not that
much different than playing on like a
desktop you know nice nice if you guys
are just joining us right now
chad is playing on the GT 75 Titan
brought to you by MSI Thank You Emma
sight and we're playing for tonight and
if you guys are just joining us and you
don't know Chad Chad is a twitch
streamer we're playing some for tonight
we out here way I heard get it we get
some people coming in and out so wanted
to keep them in the know
portal Olaf that's Fundy come on
so he is Chad a youtuber yeah I'm also
dad on Twitter and chat on Twitter at
Chad it's like it's got to be nice I'm
not that big of a social beauty like I
was telling you before but uh it's just
like it's cool it's easy for like
branding stuff too
today I like to call you dad or is this
just one guy who is calling you that ya
know there's a decent mom like call me
Dad like well it's like being around
I'll be like you know cuz I'll be like
just talk about being single but yeah
we'll find a new mom for you guys soon
don't worry you know they like it so
that's what I call you die Chad yeah I
mean they'll call me daddy daddy but I
think that's a whole other thing
okay this is squirming through the
comments yeah yeah this is really funny
mm-hmm anyone who loves everybody calls
me bad hearts hearts hearts to have his
dad who was a better gamer growing up
you were your brother
it's your time to make your brother know
the safe answer is your brother just
yeah but like was he real but does he
stream cuz it's he's dreams sure he does
EDX Cody you know if you're curious X
Teddy oh he's the one who asked the
question yeah let me see you should we
see your game no I would say
realistically I mean maybe me but I'm
gonna know it depends depends
I think I was better at a console games
yeah so how was that
that wasn't pretty crazy it stood from
console to a PC at that point um not
really because like like I said I was
kind of dabbled in in PC gaming like
ever since I was really young so it
wasn't like anything super foreign to me
even when I made the jump like buying
you know buying a PC nice
[Applause]
spell Scroll scroll Scroll scroll a lot
of questions coming in
[Applause]
all right
[Applause]
come on breath I was wondering if that
was yes so for you guys who are in the
chat who were asking about the laptop
the one that you see him playing on is
the one the game that you are seeing on
the screen this is what this is the
machine he is using to play right now
what is your favorite bug in games I
don't know if there's if it's possible
to have a favorite bug like one that you
can exploit you me me me win thankfully
like to your favorite more so I was
thinking Sims is just like funny just
like funny stuff that happens like the
the big one in pub G I think they kind
of fix it like a little bit now but the
big there's a big one in pubs you with
like that carpets like three city yeah
just like launch you yes yes like
randomly I have been launched too many
times yeah all grab a different car and
kind just like smash into each other
yeah as we could until someone's got
sent into space one time I hit a rock
and my my three seater just like yeah
just like went up for a girl Mike yeah I
think that was probably my favorite too
in pub G cuz I was just always so fun
it's fine you know it's just you just
get launched across the area tonight off
but are we playing with people and they
would like it seriously fair sometimes
dying I'm gonna say that people actually
get upset when that happens rather than
just like enjoying it and like having
fun of it yeah they get yes yeah I think
buggy games are fun I played a little
bit of Skyrim back in the day and Skyrim
those notorious for having these like
really ridiculous bugs yeah I feel like
although they're Scrolls games are kind
of like that yeah
like some weird bugs that were just
hilarious yeah and that was always a big
part of the fun there yeah yeah we
thought that bugs can really spice it up
sometimes you know they're not always
terrible
[Applause]
what was Chad's first okay we sort of
answer this before but your first game
slash platform so like the very first
game I guess you played the first game
I've ever played who ever played when
the controller hit your hands I'll try I
would like I would think maybe handheld
like an old game boy a girl game boy or
something
first game that's tough I don't know I'd
have to think back it had to be it had
to be like like a handheld game like
some sort of in Thunder game how I can't
tell you exactly what though like one of
the Mario games maybe Yoshi's Island or
something I'm like a secret in Thunder I
love but Yoshi's Island you're she's on
was awesome super net I remember I faked
sick for a whole week to play that game
I used to do that every time a new Call
of Duty came out I just mom I can't go I
can't go to school I was sick and
they're like she'd leave for work I said
that stairs hop on the Xbox's play all
day yeah yeah I used to do that all the
time
I mean any time you knew like call duty
came out and I was playing on 360 yeah
that was for me the first game I ever
did that with was Yoshi's Island I was
like in second grade ii couldn't
couldn't stop i had to beat it somebody
sounds disappoint did not pokemon if it
could have been a pokemon pokemon was
like probably a little just shortly
after that yeah it's definitely
something something like that for kids
watching don't skip school to play games
yeah that'd have to be a good influence
as bad don't be like saying it is bad
don't be like Chad's not a lobster over
okay say oh I almost got left back in
the sixth grade one for missing too much
school yeah it was definitely so you
know be good
study hard play games after
and that seemed silly for him to try to
do that yeah what was he doing plan was
there yeah I think he's just trying to
close the gap but he can yeah we miss
Lee let's close the gap in full sight
right at you that was silly that was
very silly
[Applause]
hoggers clapboys hoggers are excited do
you ever end up catching yourself saying
emotes which emotes in real life yeah
everybody's like yeah especially when I
go back home and like hang out with my
friends my high school or college and
there's like bro or this coming out of
your mouth right now yeah I love it
I think the streaming's like streaming
has made me like talk to myself I'm
pretty sure like I'll be like in the
kitchen and I'll like I'll be opening
the fridge you know like looking for a
snack and I'll see something I want in
there I'll spell all boys let's get it
we got you know we got some fruit cups
or something I'm just like Who am I
talking about snack use I can't turn
turn it off yeah he seems like the mode
and you're like going nice I heard I saw
somebody up there she's reading shot
y'all good god y'all yes I am I'm
reading the shot so if you guys have
things to say you can I am you guys I'm
just watching you guys
but if you guys have any questions throw
em at me I feel like I'm opening myself
to getting trolled here it's okay yeah
there are there yeah be like there the
hallways be like there they're trolls
they're always clowning me about some
nonsense
are you going to Disneyland asleep yeah
I'm going down to SoCal that hangout if
you know shroud oh nice hang out his
thoughts for like the week oh very cool
there you go
head up head of busyness hang out mr.
Finn senses what are you looking forward
to most Oh am I looking forward to most
Disneyland
oh it Disney do you I don't know it's
been so long I've only been in the the
one in California like one time when I
was really young so I everything I guess
just you know getting to experience it
all again nothing like in particular you
know pictures with the mouse himself
yeah yeah some sick pics I need some ID
content you know those they're some of
those character actors actually pretty
chill and so like you probably could get
one of them to do a really cool pose
yeah you know programs I want if I to
get him to dad oh great it's like a vine
or something and it was it was like a
parade and there was much of spongebob
characters and Squidward's just like
standing there and it's like it's a bad
yes I saw that I also I feel like the
well the dab is totally overrun by the
Luigi dab do have you ever seen that I
don't think so
oh my god it was in a trailer like end
of last year for it might have been the
mario rabbits trailer oh yeah we G just
like in the middle of the trailer just
dad it's like yeah I I cut it I clipped
into a gift last year oh my god it's so
stupid
I want the internet though see yeah I
went I went like viral for my first time
like like I lost my viral v card you
know I just tweeted so you know there's
like a travel ban you know blah blah
pause oh yeah yeah but the Chad thing
yeah yeah I just got Chad on Twitter so
I quote it just put finally a nothing
like
cuz like 420 thousand likes and stuff
I'll be my first like viral moment I was
like oh ho let's go
wait chai can you say I'm gonna spell
something and I need you to say it play
though it's okay
time time distract you that hard Jesus
you wanted us to get a victory sound
point pressure gif oh okay we'll see
this doesn't work cuz uh
so I used to be a design student oh so I
know it's Jeff even though like I say
give the I just can't college if it's
just it just feels wrong it does feel
wrong yeah that's like how it we were
taught okay I say Jeff till I die
it just it just doesn't feel right thank
you thank you
I took some serious heat just not the
same gift and I need it to just know I
said yeah that's the way to do it Jeff
just doesn't like it's not peanut butter
yeah yeah yeah that's all I think it I
think it was pewter yeah when I say Jeff
I'm like jiffy yeah you're like like a
car like a chicken or something like an
automobile placer yeah yeah doesn't seem
right
oh don't kill me please you trying to
win okay all right baby you stay down
there be in a box
oh okay it's face it's not it's not you
it's not me it's not you it's me
stay where is this guy now
[Music]
Dufresne dude I will end you what he was
like one of your cup and I it's so like
we can count you
oh yeah no you not trying to get like
best ready there you know no it's okay
you can go you go in go in for sure
oh they're sad they're sad they're
really sad I'm sorry boys there's a lot
on there they weren't there rooting for
you they know you're looking at China
for sure
they want to know I'm in our chat they
were asking us who's the best pop G
player you know I think this is a setup
I feel like we I mean like why is that
even a question like it's obviously me
that was the right answer definitely the
right answer to that question yeah I'm
just gonna let you guys know that in
about 15 minutes we're gonna be breaking
down the specs to this right here and
take a little a little half Point Break
so I mean if but if you're gonna get
that victory you just gonna play it all
I mean you have if we got to get it real
quick I might just have to try my
hardest to you what's your favorite drop
on the map hmm oh I like going to the
farms like oh you'll see me go like down
a fatal error in Turkey a lot of time
mm-hmm just like it's just jelly a lot
of space to kind of like do good loo
take fights yeah it's like good enough
you know but like it just depends on
feeling like you know sometimes I was
just like hit up tilt it and just drag
out go hand so it definitely just
depends on how you're trying to play I
guess
[Applause]
Jesse I can't read your name cuz it's in
light blue
Jesse sniping L just asked about if the
screen is a high refresh rate and it
does it's a 120 Hertz 3 millisecond
panel with g-sync but well I'll get into
that more later
so yes it's a pretty pretty decent
refresh rate oh yeah you gotta be over
60 nowadays voice it's 2018 you're 6
here it's monitor yeah yeah you're not
making the most of your so I have a
really embarrassing story so no okay my
monitors when I built my computer were
60 Hertz on theirs I had like at the
time I bought a nvidia geforce 970 yeah
and I had these really really crap
monitors like really bad oh no and I
didn't really realize how bad it was
until I finally got a new one yeah you
don't you don't really know until yeah
really nice yeah you don't know you just
don't know what you're missing and it's
so pointless to build a nice computer
and have really bad monitors because
it's like you're not taking energy
performance that you could anyway it's
like what
you know the graphics card or whatever
exactly if you're not like if you're
gonna go out you got to make sure that
all of your stuff is up to par don't
skimp on the monitors just because you
have one already that works yeah no I
when I was like kind of in SES playing a
lot csgo my was my first like a father
just off on six years before that dude
we're not for not for long they're like
short because I was on the family career
you know
when I build my computer I got my first
legit monitor and it's like it was like
a 144 Hertz BenQ and at the time they
were like five earning bucks I'm getting
like way cheaper now but that was like
the the top tier monitor at the time you
know it's what everyone used every other
player used it and yeah I mean it's for
necessary here on the station here what
fire dual booting why does he movie
bombed himself along with me we are you
doing sir
I shouldn't hold on this guy you know
[Applause]
I don't know if you see in here yeah
they went back up we got scared could
have gotten spooked 9 here I'm walking
oh there is oh hello game
oh geez
oh okay so I'm gonna do the mandatory
because I do see some new people coming
into chat here if you guys are just
coming in we're in the GameSpot office
or the being spent studio right now
playing some four language chat keeps
playing on this beautiful GT at seventy
five Titan brought to you by on the side
welcome I'm watching all the chats so if
you have any questions please feel free
to join us on GameSpot twitch jods
twitch our YouTube channel the website
wherever you happen to live right now no
I just 78 well this guy's insane how
much HP does the admin it's 32 cupcake
struggle I'm sorry that's rough it's
hard we weren't in span of time I was
just I always just like to make yeah I
just like to make fun of the fact that
there's a place called tomato challenge
the worst place to land - yeah Lance
made it sound like I know your noob like
you're Scott go yeah actually no it's
funny that's the first place I ever
chose to land like it looks like it
should be good but like the loop there's
kind of butt cheek so this is a perfect
time since we just started up in a game
I'm gonna be breaking down the specs for
you guys so people's behind the scenes
if we can cut to some b-roll I'm gonna
be telling you guys a little bit about
this machine no it's all good
you can keep going just in the opening
scene here so this is the MSI gt70 5
Titan and there's some of the key
features it's the latest eighth of Gen
Intel Core i nine overclocked six core
processor has a NVIDIA GeForce GTX 1080
graphics card a 120 Hertz three
millisecond panel with g-sync so it
doesn't have that problem and we were
talking about before with an old six
here this monitor has advanced cooling
as a mechanical keyboard built in which
is like an essential if you're a gamer
it's the starting price is two thousand
three hundred and ninety-nine dollars
and you can get on Newegg or Amazon so
and it's also customizable so all these
specs that I just told you a lot of them
are you know you can interchange get
them get the graphics card you want okay
keyboard he wants to man
yeah the mechanical keyboard is
definitely something that is pretty
pretty serious I was a I push back on
the mechanical thing for a while oh
really yeah
because I was just wasn't into it but it
changed my life if you guys are
wondering what I'm working with right
now we have the GE 73 Raider has this
really nice RGB lid also has the RGB
keyboard so very nice pretty nice stuff
so we can come back to the game cuz
we're in one right now it's I was
farming up some yeah it's you know I was
hanging it out
[Applause]
what kind of coffee is that it's a tea I
wasn't about coffee this morning
not feeling no I was already nervous I
Holly the more caffeine its are you
normally like a coffee person though I
like both it depends on type of day I'm
adding right for sure oh this guy does
he not know no slapping us up
oh yeah I guys I was nervous I started
it also doesn't help that I had to run
here from where I was going so I sat
down and my heart was already racing so
[Applause]
hopefully this guy doesn't push died
right now relax just calm down
this oh it's two less I don't think I
think he knows what's going on what is
what is he doing
oh okay all I did is Bob to me feels
Hills manages does of a sniper it'd be a
shame if you just fell you know
[Applause]
flamboyant waffle says y'all got a
favorite controller
I have a least favorite controller I
really I really not a huge fan of the
ps4 controllers that was nice those nice
calm thing
I like the personally I really like rock
candy controllers there third party but
I like them because they remind me of
the crystal controllers from they have
like the crystal case oh yeah yeah oh
yeah the glow yeah the makers rock candy
but yeah I personally really like those
I use that for all my PC games that I
play with the controller you can also
use it on your xbox
I usually a because they used to play
rock with a guy that played a lot in the
competitive scene in rocket League and
for the pro scene and everyone uses
controllers very pro controller yeah
yeah used a razor Wildcat actually which
is like their their xbox pc controller
it came out we got him in like an Easter
Egg for it for something and so I
started using that guys really like the
oh no his comfy fits my end night's
towel or is that way sorry Anatomy L
pieces are streamed snipers as bad and
fortnight as they are in pub G I don't
know about like somebody like ninja in
terms of extreme snipers for him or like
just in general I feel like a lot of
people don't get his mainstream snipers
I think it's easier to a launch padding
okay I'm immaterial big lace axes what's
their opinion on full time streaming oh
nice your ability to multitask this is
pretty pretty good Oh full time
streaming it's cool I kind of just made
the transition into like really taking
it seriously it's like a job it's like
this past year and it's been like good
so far I definitely see the whole like
turn your job into a hobby kind of thing
like it's great but like at the same
time it kind of changes how you look at
it right and just um just the day-to-day
life of like streaming I mean I just try
to have fun with it just do my thing and
I really you know like change take it
too seriously even though it is yes a
serious thing you know you know it's
affecting my whole life now it is my
whole life now yes but I try just have
fun with it still and you know just
focus on the important thing who live
happy thanks shaming for me it's always
been like a fun thing to do like just
like hang out and have a good time and
oh yeah you know for sure I was like
that's the main appeal for shaming for
me I think it's just hopping on just
like playing zombies and it's like
playing a [ __ ] around
mm-hm and it's cool cuz battle royale
games make it so you can just like hang
out with your squad and have a good time
and that's like fun to watch for people
yeah exactly
yeah I think I think it's very like it's
just a broadcaster or like an
entertainer I think that's right like
thrive the most just like you know when
I'm with like some good friends just
kind of going back and forth
mhm that's where I have the most fun
things that was like the popularity of
like the dayz streams yeah when they
were like a really big thing yeah that
was exactly it how's the interactions
with each other and
random people you'd run into yeah
they're like random bully extreme
snipers no dad default seeing though
he's a newbie right no skin you gotta
nice how do you feel of the sniper
rifles in this game it's interesting I I
want to see how they're played I like a
really high level like if people really
use snipers because good players will
never really a peek first right mmm
those be a holding like looking through
the side of their like wall or whatever
and then they'll a quick peek you when
they when you're like actually peeking
and they go for a shot it was kind of
like quick peek you so I don't really
know in terms like at the highest level
like how that like plays out
it's got owned so I really know how
would like to play out against like
really good players right yeah yeah I
enjoy them I've always been a big fan of
sniping in games choose uh mini Maragos
I hope I hope she reads the chat when he
when he's done and I hate to say I've
been reading the chat this whole time
[Laughter]
okay no they're definitely not being
there they're definitely being not good
vice I there's so many credit there's so
many random questions and having a hard
time I'll see them and then I like I
miss them so I'm just gonna go back a
little bit okay here we go here's a good
one - Sheldon Fullmer says what control
do you use a switch off from building to
like switch off from building yeah like
what's your talk what are your key pines
for building so my walls are on cue and
then floors or ceilings around
and then stairs is on my mouth it's like
Mouse five okay that's actually I see
that a lot um thank you yeah CUNY are
like really popular yank the mouse is a
little better though because you kind of
have to sacrifice not like too much but
you kind of have to sacrifice a little
bit of your movement you can go to it
Curie like you're you know mid-fight
eating a swap to a wall or something you
might not be able to hold w and like
keep moving forward like you know
hitting cure it ever so I like the mouse
buttons more so but it's just like
whatever is comfortable they were
surprised by my rock candy answer I'm
not for me it's not necessarily I think
that performance is always should always
be important but like I'm not competing
you're more so just like all this one's
pretty I like this one yeah to be honest
I think the aesthetic yeah like you
realize a hot topic one day and you're
like damn bees are sick yeah Wow ouch
they sell them they're pretty sure they
sell them there that was a that burns a
tiny bit Chad hot topic cig okay walking
it back no but no I you think like a
control that looks nice that performance
though is probably like the pro
controller the pro controllers right so
there you go there's my there's my
trihard answer for you guys have you no
ha yeah no okay I take it back
bang bang your graphic tees they do they
do I would be lying if I admit to buying
a tier 2
[Applause]
it's a nice place to pick up some enemy
merge sis I honest you were exactly true
watching anyway I do watch anime okay
what's your favorite of all time hold on
Full Metal Alchemist
yeah brother yeah so this is where it
gets really kind of racial I like them I
have died I like it more the Brotherhood
the first version that came out that
like deviated from the manga yeah but if
it wasn't for the movies I would say
Brotherhood okay because I feel like the
movie is made up for like the mess that
they may at the end we're going to
Andy's a diplomat here but it's it's
good it's a good one
I also never watched
Oh sad asteroid yeah I never uh that's
actually on my list like watch pretty
soon film at all it it gets really
boring in like the teens you have to
kind of push through like episodes ten
through twenty but yeah so that's just
preparing here yeah I watch watch
Brotherhood just so you can be on
everybody else's yeah yeah like one said
you just watch brother everybody says
watch brother heads I will say if you're
gonna watch that if you're gonna sing
sometime into full metal sink it into
Brotherhood yeah since it's like the
right way to watch it anyway oh for sure
I think it what's your favorite anime
actually not that's tough I don't know
Hunter x Hunter I haven't watched that
one really oh it's really good it does
have like a pretty big role in uh one of
the Arts so just like it just drags on
and gets like real boring I'd like she
like take a break and like watch
something else and I come back to it
mm-hmm
but uh I love like the character Ramon
it's really good like it's just a really
good show I'm gonna ask you this
question before you land
cuz then I'm gonna let you sink back in
but what does Chad think is gonna happen
when for a night goes live in China
it killed Punjab cheers for a night well
the same will have the same fate I think
I don't that made sense but well it will
have the same Will Forte having the same
fate as pub G when it goes to China
essentially I really know how prevalent
cheating is in a fortnight let alone
like how much that will change when they
have like a Chinese player base mm-hmm
and like the going back for the pub huge
thing like I said earlier I feel like
I really encountered that like mass
cheater wave when I was lying I'm a
physicist cuz like NMR was like too high
or like it was more prevalent very
person but uh I don't know I guess I
guess we'll see I'm no idea no idea how
like the player base you play more
first-person pop G right oh there's that
yeah nice
I also like playing first-person punchy
yeah so you got played first-person it
feels like more it just feels more fair
when you're playing it yeah 100% that
was the big us complained and complained
until they finally came out with the
first person mode because it's just like
it kind of discourages people to really
like just like play and look for action
because with their person everyone will
just kind of sit in houses and like
third-person peek around the walls until
you ended up deciding to run towards
that house and they're okay and there's
kill you you know it's so easy to die in
pub do die really fast
Ambrose jacket says Epic Games is much
better equipped to stay on top of
cheating in my opinion yeah no probably
yeah I mean they having it's really been
dishing for tonight how many yeah I'm
thinking crazy yeah I I actually didn't
really notice a chief atompub gee I
think I've only seen a cheater in action
like once yeah ever yeah like I haven't
even caught it too many times though we
will run into cheaters occasionally yeah
occasionally it hasn't affected me like
the people I go if I don't think as much
as if it has okay for other people
[Applause]
boys that
[Applause]
Joseph where lovara says how many solo
wins back in pub or and off or night
yeah he plays a lot not really too often
I just don't play as much for tonight as
a touch a lot of people yes play a lot
more fuzzy I took like a little break
though and played for like a solid week
I probably have a shoot you can probably
check my stats
I can't this game yeah if you don't want
to reveal it's okay no thanks that was a
good man oh boy
I doubt it sniper rifle
[Applause]
it all
[Applause]
oh geez
because it's open
[Applause]
boyo Oh God
today some house repairs
quiet because I want to be feeling like
focusing on this by my head Saddam yeah
it's all good
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
he doesn't have his trap music I think
is that the problem job you sick yeah I
mean it's not ideal but like you know I
love bumping some tunes
[Applause]
hey guys I'm keeping I'm keeping it
silent because I doesn't hiding in here
this whole time it's trying to be kinky
my window cheese yeah I'm Pat finger the
wrong key dude that happens to the best
of us heya spot so do you think of all
these be our games and fan bases our
single-player games going to get less
seen I don't know I feel like there's
been a lack of uh like really good good
single-player games you know got a war
just came out apparently it's pretty
cool came out uh or is that out or is it
coming it's coming out this week on the
20th yeah April 20th so and also Yakuza
is coming out that's uh I feel like we
need some like good single-player games
yeah I think a way a way out was pretty
popular people really enjoyed that I had
to play I'm going to play us one of my
friends uh it hit 1 million copies sold
yes yeah it just report yesterday sound
yeah sonic not really like a
single-player game though that's like a
two-player co-op same kind of idea I
think that there's gonna be some great
single player games out and for anybody
who is craving one that's definitely
gonna be a good year for it for sure
yeah yes Ben want one of our game
spotters here
hell yeah yeah cuz I very excited here
react is that they are yeah I'm excited
to hopefully see I think the e3 this
year will be pretty big there's
something new some new stuff oh yeah me
too
they're stalking your stats over here
for tonight stats tracker says chad has
224 wins total and fortnight I'm insane
do you look at killing the game you know
I have that many killing the game Chad
if you guys are just joining us here
this is Chad he's a switch streamer
slash I guess you can give your youtuber
also but yeah please a twitch streamer
who uploads cool stuff to his YouTube
channel he's here playing some forename
with us and hope maybe this will be
earth
we're just on the hunt for the elusive
yeah the elusive the elusive w is we're
gonna find it though hopefully yeah I'm
just focusing too much I'm trying to
like articulate you know some good
answers for you yeah I've been
distracted I've definitely been a bad
influence and distracting me Josh's
chats been distracting so he is playing
on an MSI gt70 five Titan it is a gaming
laptop it's fully equipped with all of
the best the best stuff
my tea gyrus is red that may be the next
big single player but we'll probably
have a big multi player - I think I did
redemption well if we see it this year I
mean I think it will be yes I actually I
played like the first one Red Dead
Revolver on I think is on original Xbox
mm-hm and then when the second one came
out I was like pretty sick yeah it's
definitely a good game so hopefully this
one just like they they always seem to
do it like pretty well like they know
what they're doing so yes I got I got
fate you know in the dev team it's like
Rockstar right it makes those
Hey
[Applause]
[Applause]
I think this might I'm not sure if this
is a serious question but is Chad ever
going back to GTA roleplay sorry
whatever oh and never mind I run I
believe did you kill them GTA roleplay
yeah
will I ever played again yeah that was
the question
yeah I think so it's kind of gout still
I think there's a lot of hype around it
when they first started playing it but I
gotcha I kind of just got stale and I'm
waiting they're supposed to be doing
like a really big update uh some cool
stuff and like more player slots and all
that so kind of waiting for that to come
around and then you know might get back
in you a little bit yeah this is a good
time I enjoyed playing it so I don't see
why not
should the next Red Dead receive be our
mode let's pump the brakes on the be
ours guys let's just we have some good
ones right now let's just like chillin
oh they are skin ridiculous yeah are you
healthy
yeah hey
pants and bandages or med kit you like a
chug
I'm sick
[Applause]
[Applause]
Oh sad
gamespot do you do you know chat as a
model they're having fun
what yeah guys the mics are picking up
some background eyes which is why you
can hear the fans they seem louder than
they are probably it's Mike's trying to
say I'm not a model I'm I mean they're
doesn't they're letting us know
television what
what's worse poorly or like day way
what's worse poor lute or leg day badly
leg day I mean like late days not that
big a deal
yeah if you're already late putting
yourself into a workout like you know
you're you're gonna be yeah it's
probably roses yeah misery okay you know
pain is part of the process they're
exactly the bad Lou always feels bad
Chad working out well what I would body
you okay relax
[Applause]
I think that it is inevitable they're
just having I'm just kind of speaking to
a conversation that's happening in our
Twitter chat but it's kind of inevitable
that we're gonna see more battle royale
games and game modes happen because of
the craze people know that I think
studios so people will at least give it
a shot yeah yeah I think we'll see a few
more I mean there's already a few like
that have been announced they're on the
way
Proxima was supposed to like come out
that's like a new one you know but I
think they had some server issues it
might be up now but I don't know too
much about that there's supposed to be
also like a 400 man one like this summer
anything like 400 me and BRT like Club
you came to a hundred players that
having lag and stuff I don't know about
400 people mm-hmm yeah that seems like
crazy that's a what game is that one
again with the 400 maverick yes maverick
it's just and I was interested in that
one cuz the environments looks so
beautiful but it doesn't see it seems
like it might be kind of a mess over oh
yeah see how it runs yeah
all you got a shotgun dude
just by eating meters shocking yeah yes
where he has no idea I'm falling I'm not
really sure
[Applause]
long breath I thought I saw the action
I'm not sure what was that I thought I
saw the action for him drinking but I'm
not sure I
jaelyn nice okay you're just waiting for
me he was he was trying to sweating out
here yeah trying to beat you fail
without the day not the day
nice Oh big jelly mm-hmm
trying to keep it chilled right now cuz
I'm just like give you the best best
chances the best atmosphere yes I'm
trying to get you the best atmosphere
for a win we progress forget that I've
dude I really been expecting on myself
right now
Oh Chad's probably laughing at me they
probably just making fun of me
oh no
[Applause]
they're very excited you killed the guy
though okay classic shop
[Applause]
what's Chad's favorite Chad quote my
favorite quote yeah I've said I've said
some like weird stuff Oh bull chad quote
how not deep my mods will just like spam
all the commands right now I just have
quotes on quotes and that my body
I say the market had to close it's like
a good one trying to read a book chats
going too fast oh my god
[Applause]
all right we got we got about 10 minutes
left already let me know all right well
I gotta get a dub real quick there's
gotta be the game then yeah oh wait we
actually wait sorry my time is my time
is wrong we have we definitely have more
time because normally we start normally
when we started eleven we started eleven
thirty today so I was doing the
countdown yeah we haven't Sam I'm sure I
have a good time making it alright well
my bad my bad guys my bad my clock
internally was like alright guys one
o'clock is around the corner
no we have time we have time so now we
good we're good we're good
sorry false alarm puzzler but if you're
just joining us I should let you know
that we're here with Chad we're playing
tonight on this sweet MSI gt70 v Titan
is pretty nice yeah yeah it's a gaming
laptop has me camp keyboard has it's
fully fully loaded I'm sorry I'm sorry
I'm sorry guys
Bob Jim I did not forget about GameSpot
News I'm sorry
we for people who are watching here from
GameSpot we started a GameSpot daily
news show at 11 o'clock that's why we
I'll be recently altered our stream
schedule around it so I'm operating on
on old times here that's why we're on
the 11:30 schedule now yes yes so you do
like a lot of shows every day we stream
here from 11:00 or what from 11 to 11:30
video game spot daily and then from
11:30 to around 1:00
we'll play whatever we think is people
want to see that day so new games
sometimes we get like early access to
games that are coming out so you know
we'll get to play through some God War
maybe or like when Far Cry 5 came out we
got to play that a little release so
that's you know we try to go for her for
whatever it's new yeah I have a lot of
fun with it
I didn't play Far Cry 4 so I I didn't
have Far Cry 4 was what primary was that
like different I think that was totally
a totally different game it's like weird
yeah Far Cry 4 was done with the hair
the guy with the blond hair oh they were
in Nepal I think a lot a lot alike
junkie analyst I didn't play for either
I played I played three mm-hmm and I
played a little bit this one but I
haven't really gotten to in-depth on it
yet oh no I just like yeah that's just
Far Cry like I think it's full I think
there's a lot of cool stuff to add and
it just looks really nice but it just
hasn't really like I haven't hopped on
one day I was like damn always Far Cry
you know
clem boy and waffle says do you think
traditional game media outlets will work
with streamers more in the future I
think so
I think we've we've had a number of
guests here from not just rumors but
youtubers as well so I I think that you
can expect outlets like GameSpot to
include streamers new youtubers into
their programming for sure yeah I think
it's like more prevalent nowadays it's
kind of hard to deny cuz they're just
like there's a lot more hype around
gaming in general - yeah sort of just
internet gamers are becoming like actual
celebrities you know like a lot bigger
following than people in movies and TVs
definitely it's kind of hard to do that
it's hurting tonight I was just at PAX
East and I saw jacksepticeye oh yeah and
he's cool I like its content he plays a
lot of fun games and he's fun to watch
but I saw a young girl cry oh also
hoarding for you it was not really
listening no it's totally fine I'm
watching you and stream sniping me I
thought I got it it's the same guy geez
I really thought you got him there I'm
sorry
early celebration early celebration but
I wasn't saying how I saw a girl cry
after meeting jacksepticeye and I was
like woah oh yeah yeah cuz I get i I get
that it's like a big thing but to like a
lot of young kids who are gaming and
like this is like this is celebrities to
them like this is huge stuff so yeah
right that's like that's kind of it is
like there's so many kids that are just
you know watching you - but it's like
it's weird it's a lot of just youtubers
popularity comes from just like young
kids and they look up to these people
you know totally um I was a big fan
Philip DeFranco and I remember this is
the only time I ever freaked out meeting
somebody who was famous on the Internet
oh yeah
I met Philip DeFranco after watching his
videos for like ten years or something
like eight years or something like that
and I had never been starstruck before
and I
starstruck over a youtuber really I was
yeah I was that's cool spend so much
time you know watching the video
watching that content for so long that
is this whole journey yeah I followed
this whole journey and then see him in
real life I was just like yeah that's a
sound I can relate I feel bad I make fun
of that girl who cried over
jacksepticeye but okey I am it's okay
it's okay I don't know if I'd ever get
like that worked up meeting somebody
I was I was surprised I didn't think if
I was yeah but the emotions just hit you
yeah my I got my feels
one-eye Daddy asks what is the model the
laptop he is playing on it is the GT 75
Titan brought to you by MSI if you guys
are just joining us now uh we were
playing for tonight with Chad who's
twitch streamer safe either
battle royale games and today he is
rocking it on this this bad boy
yeah I saw you I saw you dropped a
couple
what you're so hot gonna kill him so I
switched my pickaxe s sake
there's just habits from playing you
know you develop these habits and then
it seems like you're just not on point
it's just bad the I used to switch
weapons using the scroller Oh scroll
wheel oh yes
I used to use scroll I know I know it's
wrong let it learn the way though right
[Applause]
so in pub gee I never used to crow but I
I DEP the last time I played for an ion
stream with GameSpot we were doing the
weekly challenges and I totally scroll
wield straight over to my pickaxe again
and I just went to like pickaxe a guy in
the face Oh talk about embarrassing yeah
you can can you scroll wheel you got
step it up for sure so don't be like Sam
feel like shot change weapons ever in
any game no never do it don't do it guys
[Applause]
Oh dr. driller I can't even say his name
bad damn there's nothing wrong with
squirrel wheel well he says there's
nothing wrong with squirrel dude come on
dog you know gotta get off the scroll
wheel man it's just it's just not it's
not as good bro it's not the same you
got to be able to be crisp with your
weapons
some people have feeling it's about my
scroll wheel breaker I know
we support you saying there you go ah
see that's nice
there's like a rowdy bunch of like first
graders much that's like weird it's like
a lot of people I'm not loving Lea like
I just imagined them like a group of
kids basically kind of freaking out yeah
yeah they just love taking the piss out
of me at any moment they can they just
they just have to it's good that was
hilarious and usually
Bitcoin poker he says legit interest in
the laptop but since I can't get in
phone playing to watch why do i I will
go through the specs again if you're
still here and just for people who are
watching if you're curious about the
specs on the laptop this latest 8th gen
Intel Core i nîmes an overclocked 6 core
processor it has an nvidia geforce gtx
1080 so you guys know how much was kind
of these are right now this one has one
built in very nice a 120 hertz 3
millisecond panel with cheese sync so
the screen is definitely adequate has
advanced cooling mechanical keyboard she
might be able to hear right now and the
starting price is 2000 $399 it's
available on you I can Amazon and it's
customizable so you can change them the
specs and that that is the the the jazz
on the GT 75 Titan
[Applause]
let's see engine catalyst says
apparently prebuilt SAR keeper right now
because the gross increase in GPUs
that's like a real thing I'm pretty sure
yes no that is a serious thing the
increased price that you can use
definitely need pre-built a better
option for a minute I wonder how long
until that whole like cryptocurrency
GPU mining stuff dies down and like
people can actually buy graphics cards
again
some companies are trying to make up for
the fact that that's happening I know
NVIDIA recently had a wave of GPUs come
out at almost on a fee but as you can
imagine as soon as I remember as soon as
those came out they were gone and almost
like two days for 48 hours they were
just snatched that week the same people
there you know like mining Bitcoin
happened to be just like waiting for
that to buy more you know I think you're
gonna see a lot of great GPUs go on
resell like markdown in about six months
because while there are a lot of people
mining crypto right now it's like not
something that's gonna be a lot of
people are getting into it and they're
gonna realize that it's not profitable
for them right away so I think we're
gonna see a lot I don't see what happens
I change here in the near future for
GPUs or the GPU market yeah but yeah
prebuilt are good way to go right now so
[Applause]
man your chats really into the crypto
all right that yeah you got some like
big crypt boy yeah no bitcoins like
super in the currency he's always he was
talking about it he's telling me I
should like get hit
[Applause]
Cobb flip ass is the ventilation good on
that laptop yes has customizable you can
you can control the fans manually so
that the laptop stays cool it's good
ventilation I know that's a big thing
that's like laptops just like sitting on
a bed you know yeah watching Netflix oh
yeah I got to make sure you know know
that proper ventilation it's very
important you don't want to like bring
your laptop out watching no flowers it's
not worth it it's definitely not and
that shouldn't happen with this guy so
[Applause]
everybody at I mean I'm caught not seen
but how many will survive longer you
know yeah their culture that too
aggressive you're right in the center
yeah I'm shelling get some mats you know
do you jiggle weekly challenges every
week yes sometimes like when I was
playing I played like a lot of fortnight
for like a couple weeks like a week or
two actually and I would just do them
for fun like when I got bored like I was
playing syllable all day before does a
guy else like try to do these challenges
real quick
and I haven't kept up with like the past
couple weeks so like though the one the
week they did like the gnomes or
whatever like I didn't really do any of
those ones I found some gnomes like
randomly they like make like weird
sounds and snicker at you when you run
by him you know have you seen the gnomes
yeah yeah yeah that's creepy they're
creepy
they're weird that's for sure
the this week or week eight had the
dance match to check the dance
challenges oh yeah yeah so if you found
all of the dance floor locations you
need two dances on seven of them oh
there's like dance four spots now yeah
okay yeah I don't know if if we gate is
still technically happening I think that
was like last week uh yeah yeah there
were there were dance math dance floors
oh that's cool yeah it's weird actually
just like this past week I think was I
had just in flag any fortnight at all
I'll just kinda like on the pub G guy
that's like bounce back and forth you
know whatever I feel like playing
Ambrose jackass asks if you'll be doing
any streaming down in LA I will yeah
when I'm at Mikey's house we'll be
streaming boy sorry we'll be there for
quite a bit so I'll be sure to get some
extremism
does that ever do ever feel pressure to
like keep like your schedule up like you
can't really like take a vacation or
take a break yeah I definitely like that
was the main reason I was actually gonna
like take a trip back home that's not
long ago but I just like I just felt bad
about Austria maybe I felt like I had
just dream so I was like yeah it's uh it
becomes like the whole like you know
transitioning into like a full-time
thing it's a whole well the new portal
for it do you haven't got the places yes
have you seen this no I haven't seen the
port for it yet I knew it came out but I
haven't used one Orsini be used and gave
me up he just threw one at me
he's through a reporter for that yeah
I'll throw one out ham dude in there
I do its battle pump did shoots what no
you don't know you're good you're good
[Applause]
[Applause]
what nice that's great it was just blast
to me that much damage was almost over
that was good
hello program GOG that's to say hi so I
feel I have to do the shoutout playing
overwatch did I ever play overwatch is
that like a good thing for me I mean
this guy's name is just called program G
but yeah I mean I played where I I never
played over no this is not true I could
play overwatch her game so I once on
stream um yeah I played abroad for a
while all like last season and then I
didn't really play the season at all
yeah I was I got mean my main is mercy
member soummo it's okay all right
everybody in chat come on buddy please
come for me now take me away yeah some
emergency main I think after mercy I
probably like Lucia okay about the
healers yeah and I like I also like
Reinhardt a lot and so I know it's fun
Ryan hurts a lot of fun I always have so
much fun like I have more fun playing
Reinhardt than then probably mercy I
just I like getting cards at the end of
the game I'm getting those little and I
feel like a really impactful mercy so
okay I mean a good mercy is important I
couldn't was a good more solid metals
like now I don't know what the metas
like now either this I haven't I haven't
played mercy since she got reworked oh
yeah I last time I played mercy she had
full res full team res yeah and so
that's what's weird now it's totally
different
yeah Herk it changed a lot she's like
single single person rads now and Carl
just like super charges everything that
she can do so I haven't played her since
then but I do like overwatch a lot just
I've been distracted battlegrounds yeah
yeah I feel that everything just seems
like it's been vr they're easily
mmm-hmm like everyone just got on the BR
away of every game yeah it's like all my
friends are playing and so just you know
it's more fun for me to play just taking
over I'm asking for mercy that's that's
true I am have mercy on a mercy man
please not like it was funny
program G says he plays a rush in his
rank is Dimond well it better because
you're a pro yeah that's why I asked cuz
I was again G means that's why I play
don't rush us all bad guys
yeah I used to play a lot of League of
Legends and pulley too much League of
Legends yeah and I always used to laugh
whenever I would see somebody a summoner
name like best whatever na oh yeah
that's the classic yeah they're always
over like I know we're all in bronze
right now so and that's always the same
person who's like I'm well I'm climbing
o a Supply Drop Lana is that what that
is
I gotta go look you know somebody that's
like wow
me I don't die get a bunch of mass let's
go uh GDC just happened a couple weeks
ago here and Epic Games had a fortnight
llama bowl that you could ride no way
yeah it was cannibal it was a mechanical
bull but it was a mechanical llama
that's that's cool
yeah and there's a really funny video of
me riding it and falling off if you guys
if you guys want to just laugh at me
falling off of mechanical for a night
llama it's definitely on my Twitter it's
like not that far back that far back
yeah GBC just happened I don't eat a
whole lot so it was pretty ridiculous
there's a lot of fun though humble they
want you to do your biggest gaming
achievement humble brag they asked me as
well oh wow I feel like I really haven't
achieved too much I don't know it's kind
of play games and streams that's a sad
too much gaming achievement like the
thing that you the success that you like
oh a rank a high rank maybe I mean I got
like rain quantum pubs you their boards
before I really absolutely I'm like I
feel like I've never really accomplished
I feel like I'll never like my mindset
though I feel like I'll never really
think I accomplished something unless
I'm like at the top they're like rocket
League chat rocket League I guess yeah
yeah one of your viewers Thailand says
or Dylan fudge says Chad's just keeping
it real yeah oh I feel like I haven't
really accomplished like anything super
crazy but I also kind of like holding
myself to a pretty high standard
so stuff like that so yeah yeah I want
to be the best and like I'm very
competitive
what is going on here I think my biggest
gaming achievement would be my sole sole
aim
wait I'm yeah there's like a huge field
battle going on yeah
no please die yes nice no it was so good
though we're getting there
I mean you played seven per game clothes
oh that's cool this is top ten it's nice
I'll just put all do my uh my really
lame humble brag right now oh yeah it's
not even it's like not even an
achievement but for me it felt really
cool I got golden League of Legends and
I was like oh but gold is really just
above average it's like giving a beat
yeah and being really happy about
getting a be your else playing League of
Legends really some already I should
already was not you know think we could
talk about you know the burns they keep
coming I was a donor kid you know I was
about getting up so that means something
like Mo's I never really touched a be is
good he's like he's good you're like
it's like okay good for you it's like
like you're doing it like you're not
like a thoughtful you yeah it's like
you're doing a thing I guess it's like a
see is like you're like okay like when
you got to be careful like you know take
it up a little bit I remember when I got
all of the achievements and Catherine
all the Xbox 360 achieved there you go
you probably had like an insane gamer
score it's all like no I didn't have a
good gamer Scratchy oh my gamer score
was only for that game because it was
the only game I cared about achievement
zone the only one you're like a hundred
percent yeah
oh no I also did it with lollipop
chainsaw Oh bad don't even know what
that is yeah it's a it was a really fun
game well that's fun time what kind of
game is it it was just like a like a
hack and slash RPG where you just like
those are a good time yeah
so in somebody's speaking for you here
amber this Jackie's Jackie's says Chad's
has to be when he clutched that pub
gstreamer tournament fragging both
summit and Joshua G that was pretty sick
that was fun that was more so just like
cuz they're my friends though and I got
to like own them in the tournament but
uh yeah it was a time off you followed
it at all they twitch has done a couple
of these liked which rivals kind of
tournaments and it's just like an online
publishing tournament will take a bunch
of streamers and it was me and shroud as
there was a dub sternum it and like
right at the end of the game the last
people left were like my friend summit
Josh and like me Mike and then like a
couple other people mini Kurt sue I
think he was actually just in the chat a
minute ago and I was able to kill min
occur summit and Josh like all back to
back to back I was just free I was like
oh let's go you know like I was feeling
it is sick that's awesome that feels
like it's always nice to have it was
like crazy yeah friends it was just it
was great cuz like they're all like my
homies you know mm-hmm the outside of
the streaming room so it was just like
great to be able to be like I got you
you know so were you friends with those
guys before you started streaming or
before they started streaming um okay so
that's like that's sort of how we all
kind of met each other was uh um it was
like one of the you know like one of the
first broadcasters on Twitch that really
like made it into something you know
like started doing it full-time and
stuff like that and we kind of just all
played with him I really like it seemed
to speak we would all go and hang out
and everyday and just like the the homie
squads kind of formed from us with
playing games or meeting a guy in a game
and you know
I'm gonna be in our squad like he was
cool you'd hang out with us and all that
oh that's that's pretty cool and yeah
that's how that's how we kind of all we
kind of look like formed around summit
and he was just the only one really
doing the streaming thing and we all
kind just like picked it up over time
but that's kind of was it you know
introduced us all to each other and got
us like on the whole gaming thing that's
pretty cool
I've got sick how long will chat be
playing chad is propped this is probably
going to be Chad's last game we have 15
minutes left uh technically on the clock
so you know no pressure Chad really I
mean yes we've been we've been playing
for tonight for last two hours if you
guys are just coming in and you haven't
caught the stream this will be a vaad so
you can watch on youtube or on site a
gamespot.com it will be available yeah
yeah yeah
[Applause]
amnesia we'll be doing a shout out of
the socials at the end and where to find
everybody
a naval pin this is I look like I just
seen I've gotten that before you're like
I just yeah somebody somebody a few
people I've told me I love it I just see
I don't see it in person I've met her in
person - and so I'm there I don't see it
when I've been I've been with her in
person but I've gotten that on stream
before okay like I'm like looking at the
I like you on the stream and like I see
it more so like on screen on the in
person yeah in person I don't get that
but like on camera I've done that before
where is Chad from Chad that's answer
the landing Cleveland Ohio I was born
and raised Cleveland's a pretty cool
place you know it's your your standard
like urban city you know lifestyle
yeah I love Cleveland I just drove out
there a couple years ago my dad's family
is from there from a small farming town
in Ohio but I they've moved to Illyria
which is about 20 minutes from Cleveland
yeah yeah we used to play them in like
all our sports and stuff yeah so I went
out there like pretty recently and I
like leave when it's a cool City yeah
it's cool it's kind of getting like a
resurgence now I do you know a lot of
like young people are moving there what
businesses are moving so there's a lot
more like it's becoming very like modern
- like a lot of like little hipster
spots like new like trendy like cafes or
like you know whatever it is but it's
like a cool environment down there
especially down like the bank down flats
is like really nice the ground the water
there's like some restaurants clubs and
stuff it's a cool little spot is that by
like the river that lit on fire I
thought that that was the that was the
Cuyahoga River right yeah yes I think
that was like more town in like Akron
though okay so cuz the Kyle group reruns
of okay I got it
I think that was like more
Akron Canton area because actions like
burning River or something like they
have like teams named Matt or like
something like that
I'm getting confused as he has also has
family living in Akron so but I've been
all over Ohio but you know live in
Colorado you're talking about but before
but like the Ohio never leaves you
right like yeah now doesn't oh hi oh boy
leaves Ohio but yeah I don't know
probably not I'm from Jersey so like you
know they say you can take the girl out
of Jersey but you can't take the jersey
out of the girl
yeah so I don't know I think yeah I
think definitely people from Ohio are
like like recognizable you guys are
forever bonded in your struggle to
support crappy sports teams yeah yeah
but I mean we just let's not talk we
don't even have an NFL team I can't be
real
everything I learned about Cleveland I
learned from The Drew Carey Show
it's Michael transactions is that that's
what a lot of people say like I'll say
Ohio or Cleveland the big group yells
make sure yeah yeah when I say I'm from
New Jersey I was going to Jersey that's
always the thing that people like Jersey
Shore know I know either that or The
Sopranos it's like the immediate
follow-up so what do you think about
Jersey Shore it's hilarious me my
friends used to watch it oh yeah yeah
it's like it was just too funny it was
very it was very fun it was very fun
show and those people exist so like oh
yeah absolutely
reality TV like ploy that you've
actually met people like that oh yeah
yeah definitely that's great yeah no New
Jersey is very much like that you go out
to New Jersey yeah I mean that's like
those people there were a lot of them
are from like Staten Island and
Connecticut and like Long Island and so
it's actually there are people in New
Jersey that are like that though but the
people who go to the shore that are like
that they're sometimes not from New
Jersey yeah from like the lower Hudson
Bay area
yes it's a place to go to have fun yeah
oh you know your stream is gonna super
chill about for tonight until one random
person who's kind of like Hornets
you're entitled to that opinion I think
for tonight's great fondue I enjoy
playing this game yeah I was i
embarrassingly told you earlier that
I've been playing on mobile yeah man I
just AM like opening myself up to all
the roofs the court I'm a mercy man
playing mobile for tonight I mean it's
it's come for me guys it's okay
well like without mercy means like we're
gonna have so many good memes you know
he's like sure we're memes are a
legitimate role even though they get it
they get clowned a lot yes this is
chariot like who's gonna heal you if not
for your mercy mean you know it's a
finish I need healing
I need y'all needs it yielding
Oh Carrie
[Applause]
[Music]
got some shields we got some maths like
we're looking pretty good right now
there's a port over there
those morning pulses to make some plays
thank you so your chocolate it's fine
girl you do you thank you I will do me
thank you I will do my thing I will play
for tonight mobile it's that's what
we're all about
no I actually do play on PC too I just
been like it's like my bedtime beat I'm
like I'll just like lay in bed show them
that like messing around I'm pretty
mobile see the pochi mobile actually
plays like surprisingly well like it's
pretty like refreshing like fun so now I
got to try that but I wanna try it yeah
you gave it a shot punchy mobile yeah
yeah I played it like whenever they
launched it mm-hmm tried it out I mean a
lot of people can't really aim so if you
just get in a car you can like run over
half the survey but I mean it's still
fun you know it's hilarious so it's like
run people over in that yeah a lot of
people are agreeing with you and shots
yeah
[Applause]
how's the Mocambo please notice me
please you have been noticed I see
what's up
I mean I don't really see you but like I
see you metaphorically see you screen
thank you for joining us
this is a top-15 situation oh boy
scan live
[Applause]
we are circles it's gonna be closing in
oh yeah I see a boy building down the
fort
yep he's gonna keep it calm next couple
minutes cuz I'm just like yeah I mean
like it doesn't really pull my focus too
much from there like talking but I see a
guy building up he's really making a
whole holiday you need mm-hmm
see if I can snag this stuff Oh Minnie I
got too big no this only dude
Garrity heard you step you get up in
here or if you just can't keep building
up let's see money-wise building so I
[Applause]
same with a classic destroy your old
house that was so stupid just hit him
with the classic destroy your old house
yeah she's gonna go that high I mean is
that kind of asking for it that was easy
oh my god it's got snipers I'm down D oh
I didn't throw that well that was my pod
do you know what happened oh he's right
there
hold it'll does he know I got full
shield will subdued come up here gonna
have a shotgun fight he's coming for you
yeah he thinks he's gonna I mean
nice shot in the middle you didn't take
damage there
yes your good position here really close
to the next circle do not someone shoot
at me in some way
Oh more impulses let's go nice all right
relax there's life with me all this guy
listen to you I just got I just got
those two minions all right watch it
relax nice
those are your names
shielding up
I'll ask I was really making me work
nice we've been wild man yeah it's
getting crazy
strace is what is going on what is
happening
I have no idea I'm trying I'm like
meditating on a victory is this
happening right now see we get a little
dovey asking yeah it's the last game
here so after yes what your launchpads
nice
okay
you've been shot out sky before dude how
you doing how's it going
nice
we go
what and vanished
yeah no idea I don't know either
[Applause]
yes we are in the focus right now
are you afraid of the destroy your whole
building thing right now because no not
like that hi oh okay I would hear him
too
that's just like [ __ ] but that's why I'm
waiting to use this launch pad got it
got it hey where's this guy like
straight vanished yeah I don't know I
might have died actually like I don't
know someone just died so no
if they just like vanished
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh just that with their boys what's up
for them yeah he's gonna shoot me down
[Applause]
nice
oh come on
nice nice nice oh man
whatever let's make work and it's chug
drugs and everywhere yeah geez nice nice
nice nice
this next guy isn't like insane
my face
[Laughter]
[Applause]
hope there is
[Applause]
hope is not insane I get this dub what
if he knows I'm telling
oh she's super pretty
long
in this city no no I can't like what
happened they were lagging oh no
certainly no please don't do it don't do
it to me serving we like nah dude no - I
was feeling it this guy was a bob look
at him cheese that we're counting that
that's a win okay yeah cuz our internet
died doesn't mean it's not a double casa
dumb
yeah I've never seen one that was it you
put in the goodbye internet guy i
internet problems followed me everywhere
I go yeah it is yeah oh man I just need
them to smile down upon me for like one
say yeah I know yeah it's probably
probably the server's it seemed like a
bug things chatted putting in the work
there in the end that was that was
really exciting to watch I was holding
my breath the whole time for you so it
was cool getting a cup of good fight
fights and so yeah thanks guys for
watching the stream today and thank you
chat for joining us
yeah thanks we're kin game spa our
Gainesville audience find you you guys
can find me on Twitter or twitch just
Chad see hav easy at chat so hit me up
there and yeah man thank you guys for
coming and hanging out with me doing a
little you know a little different style
stream so I hope you guys enjoyed it and
hi Chad streamers or Chad viewers and
fans thank you guys for coming and
hanging out with us it's I know it's a
different style for you guys
so but you guys were really fun in chat
and I want to thank you guys for
participating one big shout out MSI for
sponsoring today's stream and one big
thank you to Chad so if you guys are
interested in seeing more games watch
streams you can check us out every day
at 11 and 11:30 until 1:00 and so we'll
see you guys tomorrow
[Music]